and uh welcome to this special
additional session of uh the treasury
committee to discuss the recent turmoil
that we've seen in the banking sector
and in particular Silicon Valley Bank UK
I'm very grateful to you governor for
finding the time to come in and speak to
us on this issue I know you've got a
hard stop at 11 30. I appreciate you
you've made time in your diary to come
in and speak to us and that we will be
talking to you about monetary policy and
inflation the next time we see you in
May so today is all about the banking
sector and starting with you Governor
may I ask the witnesses to introduce
yourselves yes Andrew Bailey government
Bank of England
Dave ramsden Deputy Governor for markets
banking payments and resolution
thank you so much now
clearly it's been a very busy time for
all of you over March and would you say
that the events that led to the rescue
of Silicon Valley Bank UK came out of
left field where you taken by surprise
yes I would say that actually
um
I mean my experience which goes about 30
years now
it's
probably the fastest pass I'm talking
about the parent back in the US to start
with actually
um the fastest passage from sort of
Health to death really since bearings
actually I'd say I mean bearings um
you know was a sort of Friday to Sunday
thing and this was pretty similar so yes
I mean I would if you don't mind draw a
distinction my credit Suite which we
might come on to which is actually much
more drawn out of fair but yes it was a
very fast passage to uh to failure so
you mentioned uh Credit Suisse uh their
governor and uh obviously quite a few of
banking stocks Regional banks in the US
we've heard in recent days uh pressure
on the share price of Deutsche Bank and
so on
um You probably won't want to comment on
areas outside the UK but I just wondered
uh whether you think today that these
individual idiosyncratic events are on
our past and that things have settled
down and this turmoil in the banking
sector in March is behind us well we've
we've sent you an assessment of the UK
banking sector and that obviously would
be very happy to discuss any points you
want to discuss out of that I think
the U.S authorities are still dealing
with you know some of the consequences
of the uh the issue in the regional
banks that manifested itself in Silicon
Valley Bank
I Think Credit Suisse I would say well
obviously as you say come on to and
happy to talk about that
um is a rather institutional specific
story about long-run issues uh in the
institution so my view and I'm certainly
I'm a very strong view of the UK banking
system is that it is in a strong
position uh but capital and liquidity
wise uh it is not showing signs of uh of
problems in that respect and we test it
as you know very extensively
um I I also think that what we saw at
the tail end of last week Friday in
particular when yeah there were there
were uh quite sharp Market movements you
know I think I think there are moves and
markets too if you like test out firms I
would not want to say that those in my
estimation are based on identified
weaknesses more than testing out I mean
there is quite a bit of testing out
going on at the moment I think
and last September see there was the
stress test of the liability driven
investing which was way outside the
parameters of any stress test that you
had run Sam have any of these
developments been outside the stress
tests of the sorts of things that you
model for well I'd make a distinction
here between the capital treatment of
interest rate risk which was a relevant
factor in the demise of the parent Bank
Silicon Valley
we do capitalize that risk very
thoroughly for UK Banks including by the
way for Silicon Valley Bank UK and yeah
I'm entirely content that the stresses
we've seen are inside the types of
stresses that we apply for Capital
purposes where I think there might be
more of a policy question it's an
international question in which we'll
take close interest is around the
calibration of the liquidity coverage
ratio so that's the sort of one month
liquidity if you like the banks have to
hold and
um as Andrew was just mentioning
a very striking feature of the Silicon
Valley Bank Run not so much of the
credit series one by the way was just
the speed with which it took place and I
think the table in Andrew's letter quite
helpful what you can see is basically
three billion deposits or 2.9 going out
in a day on Friday the 9th of March um
the sort of outflow rates that we have
so the percentage of deposits that are
assumed to run out in their LCR ratio
some actually are 100 so deposits from
financial institutions are assumed all
to go but operational deposits are less
than that and Retail deposits less still
so I think there's going to be a
question for all of us as to whether but
it is a question of size whether those
outflow rates are quite High Enough
well I think
um it's much easier now isn't it to move
your deposits electronically you don't
have to queue round the block to take
your money out of a particular Bank you
can move it within seconds and so
presumably you will have to think about
what it is that you stress test for when
you're looking at some of these rules
yeah I think I think that's right I mean
all of us can move money you know from
our accounts in a short time and it's
taken me to answer this question as you
say and that is a relatively new feature
of the market the other aspect that
we've had and we have dealt with by the
way in various situations in the past
but it's more prominent is the speed
with which news can travel particularly
among communities and sometimes sort of
uh through through private messaging
groups that is a noticeable phenomen
both here and elsewhere I do think that
in this case you also had an issue that
you asked about in your letter which was
the concentrated nature of the deposit
base of this particular firm I think
that was an exacerbating Factor but
we're going to have to look at all that
for sure and and
um
governor in terms of
um the events of March I'm not sure that
I heard a clear sort of yes no answer to
my question about were these some
pressures at idiosyncratic cases around
the world it was is this something more
systemic and would you be able to say
today as we end near the end of March
that this turmoil is behind us
well I think there is a story in the
Silicon Valley Bank U.S case which I
think we will come on to I'm sure which
is to do with the treatment of it what
we call interest rate risk in the
banking book so this is not trading
activity this is interest rate was in
the bank
um we treat that differently in our
Capital regime which I think we set out
in the in the paper we sent you and I'm
happy to it would be happy to go through
that
um we treat it differently to the US
um and that is an important difference I
think there is an issue there
um because of course that obviously goes
back
that is an issue but it's not I think an
issue in in the UK because we do treat
it differently and that obviously
relates to the question of the you know
of the rise in interest rates and how
much and how quickly
I think there's a lot that was there was
a lot that was idiosyncratic about
Credit Suisse
um uh which we
have to say a bit about it but obviously
it's not one of ours as a parent now
to your question I don't think that any
of them when we've said this that any of
these you know features cause you know
stress in the UK banking system but yeah
the definitive yes no answer your
question goes back to what you said
about the markets last week they are
trying on to find points of weakness at
the moment now I don't think we are at
all in the place we were in in 2007-8
we're a very different place to then but
yeah we have to be very Vigilant so you
know if I give you the answer I don't
think there's a problem going forward I
do not want to give you for a moment the
idea that we are not very Vigilant
because we are we are in a period of
very heightened you know frankly tension
and alertness and we will go on being
good yeah so anyway that's the that's
the message I'd really like to give you
if you don't mind in answering that
question okay thank you
um Dave you wanted to make yeah
thanks chair all I wanted to really do
was was illustrate that the point Andrew
was making about the wider context I
mean when you think of what's going on
in Global Financial markets at the
moment I mean the U.S treasury market
one of the most liquid in the world
implied volatility last week close to
post-global financial crisis highs so
you've got the the recent
events in these particular banks that
have you know the markets have responded
to and as Andrew says are testing but
that that also plays into a longer term
picture you know we've all appeared
before you to talk about the ldi episode
last Autumn where you've seen these
events you know off the scale moves in
markets triggering
um uh responses so I think we this is
why we have to remain incredibly
Vigilant looking for you know focusing
and monitoring very closely as we've
actually said last week in the monetary
policy committee minutes you know we'll
keep a close eye on Bank funding costs
uh what the consequences of those could
be for households and businesses equally
looking out for other other risk factors
but we you know we have to remain
incredibly Vigilant I I I would just
note that in terms of the Government
Bond markets you mentioned U.S
treasuries you know two of the big
buyers which were the Federal Reserve
Bank and
China probably not buying as much as as
before and so I I do uh accept that
you'll need to be vigilant on those
risks
um Anthony thank you chair
um so my questions are really going to
focus on um uh whether Silicon Valley
Bank was prepared or not or how well
prepared so on Thursday the 9th of March
I think I'm right in saying that if your
assessment of Silicon Valley Bank would
be that it met all the regulatory
requirements yeah UK Silicon Valley Bank
UK uh it met all the regulation
requirements you've expected of it it
was uh well capitalized it had the right
liquidity coverage ratio it was closely
supervised by you you had the
information you needed about it and yeah
it collapsed the following day doesn't
that suggest that your supervisory
regime and criteria simply aren't fit
for purpose
well let me start I'm sure you know
someone wants to come in
keep on to meet two key points to you to
start with
no subsidiary
can be expected to survive the failure
of its parent I don't think that is a
reasonable expectation I mean they're
too tightly Associated and connected to
to do that so
foreign
I would not work on the basis of that
expectation now by the way one of they
think the key things that was done
and it was done last summer it took
about two years to do was that Silicon
Valley Bank UK was a branch until then
now it it passed through the points in
our policy where there's a level of fscs
protected deposits and if they if a
branch goes a foreign Branch goes above
that level then we say that you need to
subsidiarize and it did that and I want
to stress that because had it not done
that had we still had a branch on our
hands it would have been altogether much
more difficult situation so that's
important it was sub-siturized
the point I want to make you said you
know I said in response here well no
subsidiary Will Survive the failure as
parent but that's not the end of the
story because what we had I think on our
hands was a well-capitalized subsidiary
and it had strong liquidity as Sam's
just said it you know it lost about 30
percent of its deposits in one day but
it did have the cash cash buffers to to
meet those to meet those outflows
now that's important because what it
meant is that going into the weekend
we were working with a bank
that you know there was a reasonable
prospect that we could do something to
to resolve it which would come out on
the other side as it did with it with a
purchase frankly if the bank's not
solvent going into the weekend that that
becomes you know immeasurably harder so
so I would emphasize I don't think you
can expect subsidiary we should not work
on the assumption that subsidiaries Will
Survive the failure of their parents but
what we must do is have the subsidiary
in a you know in a good state so that
when we then turn to resolution we can
do something with it
I think the team did a very good job of
making sure that the UK subsidiary was
capitalized including concentration risk
um and on interest rate risk um but back
to your your original question look
there is a bit of a trade-off in these
things we could remove run risk from
banks by requiring 100 outflow of all
deposits to be held in reserves at the
bank of England
um but we're choosing not to do that we
do not want to operate a zero Federal
regime because there will be some
significant costs in terms of
availability of lending to the economy
and that's the trade-off that is made in
all regulations having said that I won't
repeat what I said earlier but I do
think we've got to look back at these
outflow rates in the LCR specifically
and say what have we learned from this
also in due course what have they learn
from the other banks in the states that
we're not involved with
so is it is it as far as your concern at
the moment obviously it's only a couple
of weeks but it's it's that outflow rate
is the main thing there's nothing else
you'd need I'm just trying to say a lot
on Thursday you thought it's a totally
healthy solid subsidiary it collapses
the next day you know what else is it
that you need to know to be confident uh
that it really was healthy when it was
actually on the verge of dropping debt
well I think there's the point that
Andrew is referring to before which is
there are some differences between how
the interest rate risk the banks carry
is dealt with for smaller U.S banks and
how we deal with it in our our system
and
um my colleague in the FED Michael Barr
has has confirmed that he's going to
bring forward some proposals about how
they run that part of U.S regulations
actually they're going to do that pretty
quickly I think by the first of May
um but the three main distinctions are
one is that the the accounting is
different and the U.S Gap is much more
accommodating of what's called Auto
maturity
secondly the way that
um smaller firms but quite large banks
in our terms in the US are allowed to
deal with the remaining part of their
bomb portfolios which are available for
sale from a capital point of view is
different so they have an exemption they
don't have potatoes losses through to
Capital that's an exception they can
choose to use SUV us did use that we
don't allow that in our system
and thirdly we capitalize very
explicitly in what we call pillar 2A and
minimum requirements that risk so I you
know having looked back through this
episode
um I think all of those things in our
system are working fine our U.S
colleagues I think have been doing a
fantastic job but they have said
themselves taking a look at how that
works in their system
we've both mentioned the concentration
risk in the Silicon Valley Bank because
it was a narrow narrow sector uh
obviously
um and you required extra capitalization
for that are you are you confident that
you measured the concentration risk
right and the the cap extra Capital that
it had was sufficient for that because
part of the reason why the Run was so
rapid was that it was a small Network
group of people who uh uh I mean there's
a few VC bonds told all their clients to
withdraw their money to the internet a
few WhatsApp messages and but also those
clients uh certainly a lot of cases were
required to hold their entire capital in
Silicon Valley Bank and so it's quite
natural for them to try and draw it as
quickly as possible so how do you
measured the concentration properly and
were your mitigations to Capital
sufficient
what I would say on the on the capital
side 100 I feel completely confident
about that I've got no reason to to uh
question the way that was done
um but coming onto the liquidity side
um as I say the regime that we've got
was implemented in full for this firm as
Andrew said that it's actually quite
interesting if you look at the bouncy
what you can see is they're having to
pay out the deposits with cash on that
day they're also having to sell some of
their liquid assets you can see about
700 million liquid assets that'll work
fine our problem was that we thought
confidence had been lost in the
institution overall because of what was
happening at a parent so significantly
that that wasn't going to be able to be
sustained and I do think we're going to
need to come back not particularly for
this firm but with that learning also
the point that the chair was making
around the speed at which money can move
and say well actually have we got those
outflow rates right but but I'd finish
by saying
you don't want to cover that risk
completely because the only way to cover
it completely is to you know go the
route that I just described so you'll
always have a judgment there but I think
we should revisit question that judgment
based on what we've learned so certainly
in the US and I believe in the UK as
well that I might be wrong but the the
Silicon Valley Bank often required its
clients to hold all their Capital with
them rather than elsewhere and I
certainly know I've spoken to uh Tech
firms who are customers of Silicon
Valley Bank they wanted their banking
facilities and they were required to
hold all their capital and they so they
hadn't tried to diversify you've got 100
million pounds you don't normally Hold
It All in One Bank you try and put it in
a range of Institutions to make sure
that if something like this does happen
you don't you don't face wiping out is
that um that restrictive practice that
spb have I know it's been subject to
commentary in the U.S does that cause
concern for you as a as a regulator
well I think
um
to the extent it exacerbates rum risk I
think that's why we'd really worry about
it on the asset side from a capital
point of view I think that's a
commercial choice that can be made and
we just need to make sure we capture
property in our requirements which which
I think we have I would say that that
arrangement I think was quite unusual
um but it light for you is very striking
to me that and of course we had a huge
amount of inbound over the weekend that
we're talking about from firms that many
firms did find themselves in this very
concentrated
um position that exacerbated their
exposure I'm sorry I was going to say
another point that I you know I think we
will naturally have to look at but it's
a broader point it's not not just the
regulation point is that something that
businesses say to me and actually I mean
particularly start-up businesses but
it's not just start-up businesses that
opening you know many business accounts
with to get a sort of Diversified range
of banks is not easy this I think there
is a point there
that dozens of account opening for
businesses can I just ask in you in your
opinion either way do you think that it
having that concentration of your
capital in One Bank do you think that
anopology like that do you think it does
exacerbate wrong risk because the
clients face complete wiping out as
opposed to just losing a portion of
their money look I think when you've got
a combination of
individual firm is very concentrated so
they haven't Diversified themselves and
that client base itself also being very
concentrated I think you can see how
that could lead to a higher high run
risk I think that is one of the
learnings from us I'm very Tech very
tech savvy so yeah you know already
using the kind of
um messaging and the like for for more
conventional messaging that then you
know you can really go on it when you're
in when you're in a run situation
I think it'd be good to use look at
whether the point Andrew made about is
difficult for companies to open multiple
bank accounts whether that should be
something you look at because it's
clearly a lot more stable from a
economic stability point of view if
companies are encouraged allowed to
facilitated to have multiple bank
accounts where the deposits are rather
than holding all their all the VC money
they raise in one firm which is clearly
high risk economically
may I just briefly turn to the bank's
approach to resolving
the UK
interaction with the treasury and what
alternative
um options were being considered
um on the 10th Friday the 10th the bank
published a statement that said You
intended to place svb UK into a bank
consultancy procedure
um
your subsequent letter to us then went
on to say that a sale would better
promote public confidence and stability
of the UK Financial system so I suppose
my question to Dave if I may is what
caused you or the bank to change course
and pursue a sale of svb UK instead and
if a sale was going to be the better
outcome why weren't you pursuing that in
the first place
I mean when we are starting they will
come in can I make a crucial Point here
we could not guarantee that a sale would
take place until around about probably
around about 4 a.m Sunday Sunday morning
going into Monday
so Monday morning Monday morning sorry
yeah
the reason we said what we said on
Friday evening was was really three
points to it first
I mean the the bank consolacy procedure
is the standard procedure for smaller
Banks we know that we can execute that
procedure over a weekend so we can give
certainty that there is a solution that
we can execute and that's important it
was important for two reasons once to
give certainty that we can do that the
second was to make the very clear
statement that goes with that that this
bank was not in our view a systemic risk
to the financial stability and that's
critically important we had to draw a
line and say this is not you know this
is not a bigger problem
the third thing is that in effect that
statement then puts the bank up for sale
now we have quite a lot of tools that we
can use in the resolution toolkit
we made a a an important it was an
important statement in that important
form of words in that statement which is
yeah if you know if further information
came to light we would act upon it and
that's exactly what we did we then went
into a process over the weekend
a sale auction became you know a clear
possibility and they won't be answered
and we were then able to reconsider the
resolution objectives from the point of
view of what would deliver the best
outcome for our objectives and once we
knew that we had a sale that we could do
then we concluded that's a better option
on Friday evening we couldn't say that
no and and we you know we we have a
preferred resolution strategy for every
institution that we're responsible for
and the one for svb UK was Bank
insolvency procedure and for all the
reasons Andrew gives
it it made sense to clearly give that
signal on Friday evening with with as
Andrew says the phrase
absent any meaningful further
information
for me I think of it as a what what
you're what you're doing by announcing
that is you've got a credible counter
factual that you can then assess the
alternative options that come along uh
over the weekend
hopefully you know you can't guarantee
it that you can assess against an option
you know you can deliver it I suppose
what you're saying is that you need to
ensure that you get the message out or
want confidence and stability whilst
leaving the door exactly so I get that I
get that can you can you just perhaps
then explain the role of the treasury in
all of this because we saw the transfer
statement a few days later
um to what extent did the treasury bring
pressure to bear with regards to
you know the preferred option of a sale
um and I within that
um can I perhaps want to explore further
whether there was a little bit in the
nicest possible way of ignorance as to
the importance of the customer base to
the UK economy uh it does feel through
subsequent actions and the involvement
of the economic secretary when you said
subsequent emerging developments may
clear the risks to the firm's customer
base in particular those in the
technology and Life Sciences sectors
um meant it was a public interest in
ensuring uncovered depositors etc etc I
mean I suppose I'm asking to what ex if
you could just take us through the
interaction with the treasury
and with that give us some sort of
flavor as to
whether the nature of the customer base
the UK customer base was a factor in the
bank's decision making
well I would start by saying it's not
just the treasury that would prefer a
sale we would prefer assailants a better
outcome so if we can if we can affect a
sale we would always do that
um and you know fortunately in this case
we did
so that's always our preference secondly
we work very closely with the treasury
the ACT if you you know if you go
through the act the ACT actually sets
out to a pretty tight relationship
between us and the treasury on this and
that's important
um it was brought for several reasons I
mean yeah there is always a a risk that
there might need to be a bigger public
intervention it wasn't the case here but
there is a risk
so we followed through on that
I mean I think the point I think you
make an interesting point about the sort
of the technology and Life Sciences
sector and I you know I think it's
important as well so please don't in any
sense think we don't agree with that
point what I would draw a distinction
and I think this is an important
distinction is that the Judgment we had
to make on Friday evening was about the
stability of the financial system and
financial stability
um you know I was criticized at some
course saying well you don't understand
systemic stability because there's
another system out there which is the
you know the tech and the life sciences
no I do understand that
um we had to make a particular judgment
on you know according to our powers but
of course yes if we could if we could as
we managed to do a factor sale that
preserve continuity of banking for these
you know these important businesses will
do it okay I just wanted to
there are two it's really important that
we're kind of open and transparent I
think about the relationship between the
authorities and the the Banking Act is
very clear and then in in the form with
which we exercise our resolution
resolution tools through the resolution
conditions assessment that we have to
make the role of the treasury is very
clear you know we're responsible for
um deciding on the tool unless there is
a risk to public funds where absolutely
it is right that the treasury should
lead on that
um
and and I think that's a really
important
um way to frame things we can give kind
of technocratic advice and make
assessments but where public funds come
into play and so that's why we involve
the treasury as appropriate through as
we do it on the Friday evening on the
resolution conditions assessment that
got us to the bank insolvency procedure
then in the early hours on the Monday
morning that affected the resolution if
I may though can I just press you on the
nature of the customer base
um this is deemed to be a high growth
area for the UK it's a deemed to be an
area where we have world leaders across
the Spectrum an important part of the
economy of your life for the future I
mean to what extent was that a factor
in your decision ultimately your
preferred option to take the preferred
option of actually a sale to a bank like
HSBC it wasn't in the sense that if if
we can sell a bank over a weekend we'll
sell a bank yeah and it doesn't really
matter what its customer base is because
that's a better outcome for the
customers
um so it didn't it didn't make the
difference in that sense what I would
say however is that given obviously as
you say the important nature of the of
the customer base and The Wider
importance of the economy I'm very
pleased that we were able to do it yeah
okay but we're always conscious of the
depositor base and you know particularly
if there are going to be uncovered
depositors we'll you know we we're
conscious of the context we're trying to
sell a bank
don't have to do it very often as it
happens we haven't done a resolution
since 2011
um which actually in that case the south
sea case was it was a bank consultancy
procedure but we'll look at the bank of
England will be my you know we'll be
aware but that's why we have to consult
also with the financial services
compensation scheme but it's not a kind
of it's not a crucial factor for us in
exercising our parents okay thank you
very much thank you John thank you so
really you're saying that the bank
insolvency procedure Governor is the
back stock
yes and we're talking about a small bank
here and so you put that backstop in on
the Friday and then presumably spent the
weekend hunting around for better
options well actually we spent the
weekend
work making sure that we could then
deliver on that backstop it's really
important to understand that when you're
going through even with a small Bank a
resolution weekend is is going to have
lots of twists and turns in it so you
have to for it to be a credible
counterfactual you have to be able to
deliver that on the on the Monday so you
have to you know get an insolvency
practitioner sorted out have all the
engagement you know all the engagement
with the firm to ensure that all the all
the white you know you're not going to
get any wires across equally then
alongside that you'll be running uh
you'll be looking for a purchaser
um and and that's just the nature of a
resolution we've got multiple tools and
we as we set out in our letter to you
you know the the choice of tools you'll
be you'll be wanting to have more than
one in play and then where you end up
will depend on the circumstances of the
particular resolution I mean we have the
the bank consultancy procedure team
was working on that process until 4am on
Monday morning
because if there's any sales you can
fall throughout the last time yeah well
I've I've done a resolution in the past
I was actually quite some of the head of
UK presence which fell through it about
three at three a.m on Monday morning
yeah and in which case if you don't
encode for an insolvency procedure you
might fall back on a bridge Bank yeah
yeah so you've you'll you've got you you
need to have multiple options and that's
the great thing about the resolution
regime that it compared to where we were
when I was you know remember it well in
the treasury where the only two options
we had during the global financial
crisis were either you allow the bank to
fail and risk Financial stability or you
get a bailout from public funds which
comes back to the answer I gave you
uh Mr Baron were there other Banks other
than HSBC that were
um sniffing around as potential buyers
because it's quite a big book of
companies that although some of them are
risky they may grow
um and and HSBC got it for a pound well
there are a few other people
Silicon Valley Bank UK set up a
so-called data room are they hired
advisors throughout from sort of late
Saturday throughout Sunday that data
room was open and quite yeah quite a few
people came into that data and to have a
look
there were a number of possible offers
but yeah I've had quite a lot of
experience of doing these things you
know most of them don't turn into
anything real and then occasionally you
get ones where they set conditions and
you say no sorry we can't do that
um so by the end of that process and by
that I mean sort of really sort of into
into the sort of earlier part of the
evening on Sunday so this is around sort
of seven eight o'clock on Sunday evening
we really only had one left and that was
HSBC and um what uh what due diligence
guarantees did they do on the book did
they do all of that over the weekend
said it was clear to us that in the
early evening of Sunday we needed to
narrow down the sale option to to one
based on on what we had at that point it
was so in terms of just games the line
by seven in the morning
um uh HSBC can speak themselves but they
went into the data room
um they this was you know
extraordinarily high pressure situation
with lots of us working both nights over
the weekend yeah
um and HSBC therefore didn't have much
time for your question but they did have
some time uh they did a lot of diligence
fairly intensively and they prepared
their teams during the Sunday and then
there were further yards of that that
had to be done late into Sunday night
and early into Monday morning which is
why of course we had to keep the other
options going in case something emerged
from that having said all that
um
there was a risk judgment that HSBC had
to make around did this look attractive
enough commercially that they were happy
to run the risk of doing something at a
much higher speed than they would
normally choose to do and didn't give me
any answer that question was yes
um but but you I mean there were quid
pro quoers weren't there which were an I
mean we had the stature instrument
yesterday which changed the
um ring fencing regime so there are
quick Pro close here presumably to give
them Comfort well there were only this
was an important part by the way of
yhsbc was a credible they only really
asked for two things one was change and
control approval so they're not allowed
to take it over unless we agree
um and the second was around ring
fencing do you want to go into that now
I can I think there are
but
but just
that they were clear well perhaps come
on to this because he's gonna go they
were very clear that a necessary
condition for them uh was there's some
some announcers made there and
and understand your point the valuation
in the time available we carried out an
independent internal valuation I mean as
in we did the valuation
um uh as opposed to anyone else to you
know
um of of what you know under stress
circumstances what the bank
was worth and that's what you know
that's what led to the the the share
transfer and taking place at a value of
a pound because we had to mark down
um the balance sheet very significant I
was only going to add it sort of goes
back to Mr Brown's question that
someone made the point that of course
they were still having to make a
judgment on the value of the assets that
judgment is easier because there was
Capital the bank had Capital yeah and
it's much easier to make that judgment
that if it doesn't have capital and that
that Capital as well as the Regulatory
and you know all the capital was owned
by the parent
which was also you know from our
perspective it made it very
straightforward
and I suppose the the other issue is
um going forward for smaller Banks does
the insolvency procedure
is it a viable option
um and therefore does it have teeth as a
part of your toolbox because clearly you
you're anxious to avoid it what would
have been the outcome had it had this
bank had to go into the insolvency
procedure had HSBC got cold feet and run
away at 3am on on Monday morning what
would you have been left with well I
think it is a viable procedure yeah I
mean I mean Dave said earlier we've used
it in the past
um
what I think would have happened what
would have happened is that the insured
deposits would have been paid out within
seven days now they're not they were not
a very big proportion of the total
deposits but they would have been paid
out
the uninsured deposits would then have
been paid out as the insolvency
practitioners realized the value of the
assets
I think there is a you know there is a
very reasonable chance that they would
have been paid out in full because of
the capital base that the bank had but
you can't tell that definitively and
until it actually happens I think of
course the effect and this goes back to
the effect on the on the businesses on
the biotech and fintech businesses of
course is that even though they you know
had a reasonable Prospect they'd have
been paid out in full they would have
had to wait for that to happen
that's the crucial point I think that
from quantity of the liquidity of those
businesses
they would have seen a very a very
substantial effect particularly for
payroll on Monday yes exactly yeah and
if you think about what um the U.S uh
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation is
having to do with its management of the
parent you know it's now involved in a
in a bridge Bank setup guaranteed the
entire entirety of the deposits with
blue loss at all but it's also managing
generous bonuses I think but it is also
managing you know I think yesterday was
announced that it had managed to sell
some of the book to another bank so it's
working through
uh the balance sheet in that way and we
you know we if we'd gone down the bridge
Bank we would have been in that position
but just to reinforce Andrew's point I
think absolutely
you know we need the bank consultancy
procedure as as one of the three
potential strategies along with partial
transfer and bail in that how we
approach it the banks that you know that
we're the resolution Authority fall it's
it's it's still an important the key
issue is who Bears the cost yeah now I
think in this case because the bank had
Capital laws I was just saying a moment
ago it may have been there wouldn't be a
cost but there would have been a cost in
terms of liquidity for the for the firms
but the key issue here is who Bears the
cost in the in the bank consultancy
process it's the uninsured deposits that
are you know standing in line
effectively after you've taken out
whatever is left on the capital and uh
side but let's assume there isn't for a
moment
um if you go to the big Banks we've put
in place so-called bailin regimes where
they issue debt that yeah that can be
bailed into better the losses uh to
recapitalize the bank uh but in in the
bank and solvency procedure I mean that
is the key point is that the losses
would more likely fall through into the
uninsured deposits
thank you thank you very much Angela
Siobhan thank you
um could I ask you uh Mr belly existing
legislation already makes Silicon Valley
Bank exempt from ring fencing rules for
four years after its resolution what do
you make of the government's intention
to make this exemption permanent would
you mind if I mean Sam's the experts on
ring fencing would you
so the one is that um
government very wisely in drafting the
Banking Act has allowed for a four-year
exemption but thinking about exactly
this kind of a situation where a ring
fence bank is buying another bank in a
distressed situation or resolution
situation and that gives the other bank
four years to come into line with
repressing legislation nothing had to be
done to make that happen that just
automatically followed just as you said
um a second thing which did need to be
done very urgently given the situation
we were in was that it was important
that on the Monday morning at 7am
um HSBC was able to fund Silicon Valley
Bank UK without restriction because we
were in the middle of this very high
speed run and of course we thought the
sale would reveal confidence but there
can be a lag effect so the treasury
needed to lay a section 75 border which
I think actually was just debated in the
um you're referring to the delegates
committee yesterday which was just to
allow them to lend freely because that's
obviously not an armed length type of
transaction the the third piece is more
directly on
what you're asking about which is that
the the treasury has agreed to make a
permanent exemption uh for svb UK within
HSBC uh UK within America they do that
because they were desperate for somebody
to take the bank and we're happy to Cave
into hsbc's demands well look I'll I'll
explain to you what their rationale was
and give you my view on it
um as I said if HSBC did not seek many
things in this transaction but they were
absolutely clear that a necessary
condition of them being willing to go
forward was that they could keep the
entirety of SBB UK as one business
because they thought that the the
integrated nature of the business was
part of the value they were getting and
they could only make the numbers work if
they had it as a subsidiary of HSBC UK
so so the the treasury faced a trade-off
there
um do they agree to make a very small
hole in the wing fence permanently in
order to get this one over the line to
serve the wider objectives that we were
looking to achieve over the weekend or
do they know and they decided that they
should but what it's worth I think is a
good call
um I probably am one of the very last
people on Earth who would support
punching any kind of a hole in the ring
fence but this is very very small in
relation to HSBC if I might expect one
more comment though I think something
that we should be alert to is
um
I think it would be a very bad thing if
other Banks sought to say that because
this had happened in this one case that
needed to be generalized for everyone in
business as usual you might face the
same situation again in a stress
takeover like this which case you might
have to think about it but I can see an
argument might come sail because that
little hole has made everyone's going to
have their little hole it's not almost
inevitable I it may be inevitable but if
it comes I think we should resist it
there is a big distinction I think
between a stress event and you know the
kind of environment that we think we're
going to be going into that you know the
the ski op review was thinking about you
know this is a reminder that stressed
events happens and and the banks fail so
I think it's really important that we
have a ring fencing regime that that can
that works in good times as well as bad
I mean there's another piece of in my
company which is it's important that
when that that order has not yet been
brought forward to the house so we'll be
able to debate it
um it's important of course that the
that permanent exemption is suitably
limited both in terms of size and in
terms of the shape of the business
because what you obviously wouldn't want
to do is say okay well we've allowed
this very very small hole in defense and
you turn around is suddenly a massive
one so um that'll be an important part
of it is that how holes normally happen
well depends on the robustness of the
rest of the fence is very robust I think
it would be okay What proportion of
Silicon Valley Bank's business would not
ordinarily be allowed to be undertaken
by a ring fence Bank it would be I can't
give you a precise percentage but it
would be quite significant for the
reason that
um a certain amount of the lending quite
a significant portion of the book
actually is in the form of subscription
Finance which is basically to bridge
um the investors in Venture funds
between making the commitment to put
money in and actually having the money
available
um those clients in that case will will
often be I think relevant financial
institutions for the purposes of ring
fencing which means that ring fence
Banks can't normally lend to them
um so I think it'd be quite significant
which is why
um it was a red line for HSBC I think
and that was why it was quite credible
that it was a red line thing
and are there any wider Prudential or
competition risks from these exemptions
for example do they Pride scope for HSBC
to take on additional business that it
would be previously have not been able
to or allowed to well I think that comes
to the limitations so if you look at the
size of SBB UK today I would serve a 10
billion balance sheet HSBC is three
trillion dollars globally I really don't
think that access risks them it could be
someone larger it still wouldn't
represent a risk
um but I think those limits are
important but I think the wider risk is
the one we've touched on a moment ago
which is if somehow this is prey denied
of other kind of business as usual
things that that I think is where you
can have a problem I can't understand I
mean I do think it's important so it
goes back to Mr balance question
actually I mean I do think it's
important that the larger banks in this
country do Provide support for um you
know high-tech biotech Industries I mean
you know we need to have them in that
market as it were to support these you
know these really important and growing
firms we have in this country so I think
the fact that I think HSBC also took a
decision that they actually wanted to
get into this business
um you know obviously they've got to
prove they can do it but it's a good
thing yeah I think it was it aligned
with what they were already thinking
about strategically it obviously came
along as an opportunity in a stress
situation but it should be part of the
the if it's good for HSBC and we want
um our large Banks to lend to precisely
the type of companies that Silicon
Valley Bank did
why would it not be good for all the
other bigger Banks
could they not reasonably say I think
we'd like access to this Market too so
please do something
um do something for us I think it comes
back to point some made a few minutes
ago about the question about
is it necessary for them to have both
sides of the balance sheets on this in
the same legal entity or not I think
that's actually a crucial question
because that's where the ring fence in a
sense creates the Restriction they can
clearly do that both sides of the
business but the referencing regime
would require them to have one side of
the business in one side of the fence on
the other side on the other side of the
fence now I think in the context of key
scale tribute you can probably have that
debate I think that's a you know
sensible debate to have I think Sam has
very wisely set out why we don't want
the hole to become bigger uh you know by
not you know by not thinking about it
but it's a perfectly reasonable debate
to have because there was quite an
extensive debate about small firms uh in
the context of the Ring fence when the
ring fence was uh was first put in place
you had one question yeah isn't it the
case that allowing a tiny hole to be
punched in the ring fence starts a
precedent that basically means next time
there's a problem a bank that fancies
buying that for a pound is going to that
negotiation that precedent is set isn't
it simply undermining the whole basis of
the Ring fence
so I think what I'd say that is life is
not perfect you have to make trade-offs
sometimes
um I do think it is possible that if we
found ourselves in exactly the same
situation again with a non-wing fenced
entity it's very small uh big bank
offering to take it over we're making
the same condition I I think you're
right it's quite possible one might have
to consider that and I think one should
have an open mind to that it's not
something one would want to do in normal
circumstances but I I could imagine the
characters being the same so I think we
have to be open to that but what I think
we should resist is the idea that other
people come along to sort of kick off
little I was in the fence you know
without that very extreme kind of
urgency that you had in this situation
because I mean just to because it is
worth going back to the you know we hope
we you know we have a fit and ready
resolution regime but we the key thing
is that through the work that that Sam
leads on that we don't find ourselves
having to use it
um unless we really have to this is the
first time we've used it in 12 years so
hopefully this precedent that I think
you're right to flag and which Sam has
responded on is something that is you
know this is not a repeated event
obviously we can't rule out other
resolutions they will happen but we're
not thinking that there's going to be
like you know a couple of resolutions a
month that we're then going to be this
precedent is going to become more
apparent you can't see you coming Emma
and thank you and um and thank you all
of you for your work and this must have
been quite a difficult
week or so for you all enjoy and
finishes and never ideal so thank you
um the demise of Credit Suisse looks
like a bit of a car crash in slow motion
should The Regulators have taken greater
steps earlier to prevent the smash
what I think I have to be honest we
can't speak for the Swiss Regulators
it's a Swiss back obviously the the home
regulator is the Swiss regulator we have
quite a large operation in this country
and we've taken over a long period of
time a lot of steps to make sure that
that UK operation was
probably set up and and insulated as
best we could in the event of a problem
I mean sadly I'm afraid that you're
right I think Credit Suisse has had
problems going back over a long period
of time uh it's it's managed to
stack up a lot of problems uh over time
and I think I think the real question I
think with Credit Suisse in the end was
it not actually insolvency in a sort of
very very sort of per se sense it was
actually the viability of the bank going
forwards given the given the sort of
severe sort of business model
restructuring that the chief executive
had identified needed to take place
combined with I would say two other
things one was the emergence of some
particular problems
are over in fact over the weekend of the
Silicon Valley Bank actually we were
actually able to do both together at one
stage
um particularly to do with the U.S
Securities regulatory identifying
problems in the context of their
sarbanes-oxley compliance in the US
the second thing obviously then
subsequently a couple of days later its
major shareholder indicated that it was
not going to provide more support that
is obviously a critical critical blow
for any firm and then of course I think
you have to say that there was of course
while while the proximate causes of the
of the Silicon Valley problem in the US
and the Credit Suisse problem are
different there was a coincidence of
timing and there was a lot of stress in
the market and so a bank that had been
in Long Run uh if you like sort of
viability challenge
came to the sort of Crescendo of that
moment we I mean so you know we have
taken a lot of steps over the years uh
to get in place you know the UK
operation into a place where we thought
we could deal with it if we needed to
deal with it and so that has been very
high priority for us going back you know
decade almost I would say have there
been any lessons from International
regulatory cooperation about the failure
of this and that potentially that you've
learned or ideas about how things could
have gone better and I thought it was
really interesting when I was reading
about this that was saying that the bank
had plenty of capital plenty of
liquidity but it had an issue around its
culture I thought that was well unusual
it's had a whole series of problems over
the years
can I just say when we say had plenty of
liquidity it was experiencing a run I
mean we have to be very clear on this
but it was experiencing a run and I
think if you don't mind saying so I mean
this is a very interesting question
people often say to me when that's our
problems or was it solvency or was it
liquidity and the answer on trade isn't
that simple
um it certainly had you know had a
strong Capital ratio but you have to ask
the question why were the depositors
leaving in that case
um and what I think it pointed to was
certainly what I call a viability
problem going forwards which meant that
there was a loss of confidence by its
depositors in its future viability
that's the thing so something position
is helpful and important but it doesn't
end the story at that point and to what
extent was the UK part of it as troubled
as its Swiss parent or was it was it not
this problem so I think the way if you
think about Credit Suisse in this
instance is about three-legged stool
there's the parent and also Swiss bank
in Switzerland and then there are
there's a major operation here in the UK
and there's also a big operation in the
U.S and throughout the period
particularly from October forward was a
very intensive discussion at all levels
between the FED female and ourselves
including very regular calls between
um myself and well numbers in those two
institutions including his Andrews and
over the weekend that we were dealing
with the Silicon Valley we're also in
touch
um and I actually think that that worked
pretty well
um and those discussions are about first
of all what's the life situation with
the firm and how we managing the risks
that are there secondly about a lot of
contingency planning including some of
Dave's team about okay what are we going
to do if it comes to the crunch yeah and
that was extremely helpful when it came
to that weekend because it meant a bit
like with Silicon Valley none of the
options of that appealing but you have
got options
planning again as Sam says since last
Autumn so engaging both with the Swiss
authorities but also with the FDIC in
the U.S and we'd had meetings of the
crisis Management Group which has kind
of cross-authority you know of the the
the authorities represented in the the
three-legged stall that Sam calls it you
know in the run-up to the events of
March so we were again making sure that
we were ready in contingency planning
terms for whatever was going to play out
and then as Andrew says the crescendo
played out in a particular way
um and and you know we've we all know
what the what the outcome is today
the Lessons Learned but also the
possible impacts this would have on the
UK banking system or the future of
the UK part of credit Suite so I'm kind
of keen to know sort of
are we to expect any any more concerns
are we to expect some more issues other
things that could have been done being
done differently are there any other
Banks you're concerned about I'm kind of
really how it's impacting the UK
that's what I want well I mean on Credit
Suisse in the UK I would say that both
the pra and the FCA and I can sort of
speak for both going backwards have have
frankly taken a lot of actions over the
years with this fund to experience to
require cleanups to take place
um and I think that has put it in a
place where certainly from the point of
view of the sort of what happens next
the UK entities are in you know are in
good order in that sense and obviously
it's up to UBS now to decide what they
what they will do with those operations
not for us to decide what to do it's up
for UBS to decide what to do with those
operations so yeah a lot of a lot of
actions and planning over the years have
had you know not only the need to take
action at the time but had this outcome
in mind what would we do if we got to
this point I think in packages that
briefly our overwhelming priority in
these situations is to avoid a
disorderly collapse yes uh that's what
you want to avoid because that would
obviously have very big ramifications in
the financial system and because we have
a big professional set here it would
would affect us and that's what all the
planning was for and you know there was
the resolution side of it which was
absolutely ready to go there was also
always of course the possibility that
the Swiss would find some other
structure through which to deal with the
situation which in in the end they did
just some just favor to the questions
from my my uh colleague and friendship
on do you think it's the government is
right to push ahead with a wing fencing
reform in light of this turbulence in
the banking sector
so I I we talked about a bit last time I
think
um there are all those recommendations
that kids ski up made which are sensible
tweaks to the regime to make it work a
bit better without reducing its
Effectiveness and I really think they
are fine the two I think we need to keep
an eye on what one is the the
proposition which is in principle of
public sense one of course which is if
you've got a bank which is north of the
Ring fence threshold in terms of how
much deposits it has but it doesn't do
any Investment Bank at all or any tiny
tiny bit could they be allowed not to
have the regime I think that's not a
crazy proposition of itself but there
are some definitional issues because you
wouldn't want to have a situation where
you had a UK entity that was more than a
threshold you needed retail banking but
it's part of a much wider Google there's
lots of investment banking gets a pass
so we need to watch that one and the
other one which the government is taking
further evidence on uh is the the
question that sakith and his team raise
as to whether there might come a point
where if banks are resolvable they it
can be removed from the ring facts and
yeah my my view on that is
um at least for the moment that
um it's a bit of a misthink in the sense
that for those Banks withering fence
it's integral to the resolvability of
those Banks so their compliments not
substitutes and I think all of these
experiences we've been having Silicon
Valley Bank credit Suites as well
they're very difficult situations but
it's been very clear to me that there
are a series of options you have but
also that you wouldn't want to rely on
any one tool so you need to have various
things ring fencing bailing private
sector purchase and that's what you
needed to go into these situations but I
can't understand I think it's also
important in that that sort of thinking
process that it's I don't think it's
right to think of a bank as resolvable
for all time
yeah the world moves on and things
change and you have to keep coming back
to this resolvability assessment
judgment so just quickly then would you
prefer if the government paused its ring
fence reform during this
turbulence slightly difficult time how
much are you quite contemporary go ahead
I think it's fine I just think we should
keep a careful on the bits that could
potentially weaken the regime but I
think the rest of it are sensible
you know adjustments which I think
should go ahead and to be clear what the
government is doing
um is putting out as Sam was saying a
further call for evidence on this
interplay between resolvability and the
ring fencing regime but if I can just
associate myself with with Sam and
Andrew's comments you know having both
the resolution regime and then the ring
fence gives you more options and as
we've tried to describe to you that
optionality
if you're in a crisis situation is
really important and then as Andrew says
resolvability we we did a resolvability
first round of resolvability assessment
framework last year for them for the
major eight Banks
and Pub did a big publication last June
you know where we said that we thought
we'd overcome the too big to fail
problem got no attention at all of
course because then the world was calm
and no one was you know you weren't
having evidence on that kind of thing
um I think you asked me about it yeah
but you know we need
those those rafts those resolvability
assessment framework so we did the first
one after years of work and preparation
in 2022 we've got another one starting
next year meanwhile the government is go
calling for evidence on the interplay
between resolvability so there'll be
lots of opportunities for stakeholders
to input to that call for evidence
um but I think we we think that the
events of recent Times show how
important that optionality can be you
know whether in the case of a Credit
Suisse or whether in the case of a svb
UK thank you
uh Sir John Vickers said that
in my view removing room fencing would
pose over a very great risk to financial
stability do you all agree with that yes
but everybody of course yes he also then
this was another evidence to questions I
asked in the session he came to he also
said that um
there was something said in sakis
it's a kid's report and also in the
Edinburgh reform reforms package
announced by the government that while
it is worth retaining ring fence for now
there might come a day when resolution
can do the job instead uh that is the
wrong approach do you all agree with
that yeah I mean I I I think okay what
Sam just said I think resolution and
ring fencing are complements rather than
Alternatives okay
so so I mean it's quite a serious Point
that he's raising isn't he that we
should all be
uh alert and Vigilant about in terms of
where the government's heading not least
because of the recent turbulence it
brings it into short Focus
um the chancellor is giving evidence
tomorrow so
um you know I think it's important it'll
be important for us to to make sure that
the route that we go down in terms of
tweaking for improvement is one thing
complement complementarity a set of
tools that you can use deploy is one
thing but quite another in terms of what
enlightenment has written in black and
white saying that Sir John Vickers is
Raising alarm Bells about but but to be
I mean just to be clear on where the
process is think you know the government
got the Vickers I've just got the ski
Oak review and then the follow-up in
terms of this question of the you know
what we consider to be the
complementarity between the two regions
that's a call for evidence so the
government's clear that there's a
there's an opportunity for people to
feed in yeah all the relevant evidence
I'm a bit more skeptical with respect
about where the government is on this
and where you are so I we'd be really
you know we want to make sure that that
the experts uh opinions are taken
seriously and The Architects of ring
fencing
um you know they're they're well
warnings are heeded by the government in
the rush to um
to pursue reforms that that may be
problematic that's all I just want so so
just wanted to put that on the record
um going on to
um credit Suites and The Wider
implications Governor were you surprised
by the decision of Swiss the Swiss
authorities to provide some relief to
equity holders of Credit Suisse but to
fully write down the
more senior 81 debt holders
well I I'd say I don't know the you know
we don't know all this all the
circumstances and the situation the
social authorities faced and we know we
know quite a lot of it but we don't know
all of it
um there is a thing Dave was saying
there is a resolution plan for Credit
Suisse which is agreed internationally
that is that is the backstop resolution
plan the Swiss then as you can do
implemented something you know ahead of
that as it were instead of that now what
I would say is this
as I understand it the Credit Suisse 81
bonds have a different contractual
clause in them uh to I think most other
81 bonds and I can certainly tell you
that an 81 bonds issued by UK Banks
in that they have a clause in which
allows this contractual uh Wipeout if
you like to take place under certain
circumstances I'm not going to go
further than that because no doubt there
will be lots of law cases in
Switzerland's charge but that's my
understanding of it and how important is
it
it's weird we were very clear
um on the Monday after the Swiss
authorities made their announcement to
set out very clearly the position with
R8 you know with the UK Banks 81 bonds
and how the Creditor hierarchy would
would be preserved and maintained it was
very important I think for our Market to
set that out and if I could just say I
mean the reason I'll be absolutely
straightforward with you the reason that
our banks have not issued goes back
probably about a decade and we did in
the best sense term frown on some
suggestions that that might be included
because I do think and I probably you
know take a different view on this that
it does complicate things because it
makes the character hierarchy more
complicated and probably less intuitive
so we did not want our banks doing that
but I know credits which did it and
therefore it is a contractual
yeah this is a contractual provision as
I understand it that they have
the distinction Andrew is making is
between this the version of these bonds
which converts into equity which as
Andrew said is almost entirely what we
have in our Market
um and these ones that wipe out because
if you if you have the Wipeout ones
um then in a sense you have a bit of
inverted creditor hierarchy built into
the system because they are designed to
wipe out well there's still some Capital
left in the bank and we'd always thought
the other version was more desirable for
the hierarchy reason and the statement
that we made
um weekly last week on Monday
but and indeed the Europe area for it
has made a similar statement was to
emphasize that in a resolution one of
the Cardinal principles is that you
stick to the credit to hierarchy now I'm
not saying the Swiss didn't do that
because they had this different
contractual provision but we wanted to
emphasize that you know in any
resolution we will always abide by the
credit to hierarchy because that's a
cardinal Principle as we did with the
svb UK resolution
um
okay thank you um Bill winters of
Standard Chartered
um Bank the chief exec says said the big
question is how do you wipe out 17
billion dollars of 81
in a solvent bank without a review
process
um I think it has had very profound
implications for the regulation of Banks
and for the way Banks manage themselves
do you think he has a point
well I think you have to come back as I
understand it these 81 bonds had that
contractual provision in their terms and
therefore I would assume that investors
who bought them understood that that was
the case
um and and of course that was that was
the basis on which the the Swiss acted
I mean I think obviously you could see
that it did cause a disturbance in the
81 market and that is why in good part
when we end the forces and the uh Euro
system made the statement that we did
because we were very very clear that we
had to emphasize the basis on which we
would we have to treat them in any
resolution to clear any any confusion
upgrade for that so you would agree with
him then
well I think the situation incredibly
swings I think again
it's a matter of the Swiss authorities
because it comes back to a point I made
a few moments ago
which is they will have had to judge
looking forwards the solvency and
viability of the bank and what capital
protection was required to affect the
transaction with UBS
rather of courses we have to deal with
salt with Silicon Valley Bank UK well
exactly
exactly you know the sort of things that
can happen in terms of in terms of how
regulators
then have to respond in on a
case-by-case basis well I would if I
might come in the bigger picture here is
we're at a very large International Bank
which had reached the end of the road in
terms of its viability something had to
be done something had to be done that
weekend for sure
um and in the end the Swiss authorities
found a way
to stabilize the situation which
involved a purchaser involved some
losses being taken by holders of the
higher risk end of the bond stack and by
the way of course you know shelders and
credit species have had a pretty rough
ride as well so shareholders have had a
pretty rough ride as well and look I
mean I think we should expect that with
the variety of our new tools we ought to
be able to take care of these situations
short of a bailout which is the answer
we had last time around and it does go
back if you to the question that the
chair almost started with you know we
were in a situation of of and as Andrew
was just saying of both overall
volatility of markets but also real
volatility in particular segments such
as the 81 Market things are we we remain
very Vigilant
um we're we're certainly not complacent
but things are calmer than they were
that you know that Monday and you know
the pattern of previous or certainly
Financial crises I I've been involved in
is the way that things mushroom
um you know you know and other things
happen we haven't seen it I'm just
trying to understand what you're wait
I'm trying to understand whether you
agree or disagree with this statement I
think it has very profound implications
for the regulation of banks and for the
way Banks manage themselves
I mean it can't be that difficult to
just directly answer that question well
if you don't mind one I've created a
respect for Bill Winston one point I
would disagree with the amount of
challenge amount and what he wrote in
that article is that I think he said
the bank is solvent but it's but in
another part of police the question is
viability that you can't
compartmentalize those two judgments I
mean they they are part and parcel of
the overall judgment if a bank isn't
viable then it might be solvent in sort
of a sort of you know as of today and a
sort of you know Moment In Time
but if you question its viability going
forwards then you're essentially
questioning it's obviously going forward
and you have to say absolutely if
everybody thought the bank was solvent
why would why was it having a run I'm
just trying to get a straight answer
well that's the challenge I don't think
it's as simple as as Bill sets it out
okay just one final question how much of
the 17 billion dollars uh of Credit
Suisse 81 Bonds were held in the UK
well I don't know what I can tell you is
that the sca many years ago was
um banned UK retail investors buying 81
bonds because I thought they were too
complex so they should not be in the
retail sector in the UK can't stay
beyond what I mean the key thing for us
to run down in these situation is what
are the exposures of the UK Banks and UK
insurance companies and they were
minimal but and also you know these are
these are quite complex relatively
sophisticated financial instruments so
you would imagine that the people who do
hold them are are aware of the risks and
and you know that is also taken account
of to some EXT some extent in the in the
yields that they get on them thank you
thank you
thank you Danny thank you very much
um
I'm going to ask you a little bit about
the um
the the moral hazard question really and
and I'm struck by the um letter Governor
that you sent us suggesting that um by
unsure I'm going to call it by ensuring
that all deposits including those not
covered by the FC fscs remain safe
secure and accessible the bank maintain
public confidence in the stability of
the human nature Financial system
now you're talking about the stability
Financial system so it's not about the
industrial sectors that the banks
supported so I want to come on to
um and I don't think you're suggesting
there was a contagion risk we've
discussed that you seem to be suggesting
that single Banks should not fail and
specifically the uninsured depositors
should not lose their show no it seems
to be an implication
well if you're suggesting that the
public confidence and the severity of
the financial system requires that
deposits including those not covered by
the insurance scheme remains safe then
you're suggesting that the financial
system the confidence in the financial
system would have been harmed if
uninsured depositors had been harmed
well when we made the announcements on
the bip
on Friday evening of course that's
envisage that they could be or could be
going back once I made earlier about the
capital base of the bank there could be
a loss to uninsured depositors I think I
think the context that I you know we've
had in mind in making that and making
that that comment
was the position in the U.S now I I
personally understand what the US has
done
because we were we we faced the same
challenge in 2008 yeah as you may
remember and you know it was a it's a
very difficult decision to make but In
the Heat of the Moment there are times
when you have to make that judgment but
I would agree with what I think Janet
Yellen has said something about it is
this is not a state of affairs that
should be you know the norm that that
all deposits are are guaranteed
yes okay
um so your sympathetic I mean we
obviously took a different approach but
we can say that different circumstances
perhaps those are very difficulties so
on but I appreciate you don't want to
criticize another
jurisdiction but what is your what what
could you just reflect I mean you've
discussed it before but just reflect
again a little on the what you think of
the actions of the
U.S authorities and do you have concern
that moral hazard has been introduced
into the system
well I I I would say that they had to
take actions you know promptly and did
so because you know I have to say we as
I said we've been there ourselves
um you know I know how bad these
situations uh can be
and the decisions that you take at that
time are the ones you have to take at
that time to fit the times and I think
they did that and so I would not wish to
in any sense criticize them for that
um the question then is you know is how
do you work work the system out from
there I think really and what's the
steady state going forwards and I I
would not
um
support and I think this is exactly what
Janet Yellen has said
um the idea that 100 deposit guarantee
becomes a you know a norm and do you
think that Communications in the U.S
since they've been out have
I have have
increased or decreased that General
expectation that this would be repeated
or that there is now an expectation of
bailouts in the future do you think
they've helped they've exacerbated
I I
I say having been there let me say this
it is a very very difficult situation to
have to handle because once you've put a
deposit guarantee into place as a tool
to ensure frankly that you calm things
down and create some stability stop runs
happening
of course if you then go out and say
well of course you know we're not going
to continue this and you know we don't
think it should should exist you risk
starting up the very run that you've
just calmed down so you don't want to do
that on the other hand you do want to
say as best you can but this should not
become the norm and balancing those two
things is remarkably harder to have the
experience it is very hard to do yes you
do so I don't for a moment which to
criticize the US supporters they've been
dealing I think very well with a very
difficult situation thank you so back to
the back to the UK and what we've done
uh I mean as we've been discussing the
the Silicon Valley Bank UK supports a
number of key sectors in our economy or
in our future economy and I wonder
whether you
agree that
the government appears unwilling to
accept the depositors should should lose
and has worked hard with you to ensure
that didn't happen in this case uh but
do you think this is really just because
it was a bank supporting these key
Industries and I suppose I'm
you know aware that this is a this is a
sector that I mean a lot of clever
people particularly in the US you know
putting all their eggs in one broken
basket as it turned out
um but imagine if it was a in in the UK
arm was you know a Regional Bank
supporting some unfashionable industry
you know old-fashioned manufacturing or
some kind of community
Royal community depositors and so on do
you expect that you would have spent
your weekends working hard so I've had
to do it so I mean let me tell you I can
tell you that when we have to do the
resolution of the dunfermline building
Society those discussions about the
regional nature of the of the business
and the deposited base were exactly the
ones I was having with the treasury and
the chancellor at the time so you know
it's it it happens okay so it's simply
on the case of the
the bank itself rather than the sector
that it supports that those that's your
that's your problem and it comes back to
Andrew's Point earlier that you know
it's a question of where the cost will
be Bear yeah and or born sorry and then
you know and so depending on the
institution you'll always be you'll
always be alive to those considerations
but then you you in carrying out a
resolution you have to carry out the
resolution that meets the overall
resolution objectives I mean we keep
this issue under review I mean I'm
slightly oversimplify but there is a
contrast of the major Banks and we'll
just discuss this with Credit Suisse
yeah we insist that they issue they
issue more
loss bearing debt uh so they've got
they've got the capital stack that
stands after and they've got them
they've got a resolution debt slicing
their balance sheet that Dave looks up
the emerald so that that can be nailed
and that allows the bailing to happen
now for the small Banks we don't do that
um it would be very difficult for the
small Banks to issue debt into the they
can't issue debt in the same way into
the markets as large Banks come they're
not big enough to do it
um and so that yeah we do have different
resolution approaches for the small
Banks but I'm sure we'll have to come
back and look at these things as part of
what and that's the earlier question the
lessons learned from this and one thing
if I can just add one agenda that we
that we have been looking at
um is can we improve depository
um outcomes in banking solvency you know
we're working with UK Finance on that
the
but but you know that that's one thing
in terms of speeding
um speeding up uh payments to ensure
depositors
but you still have the issue that as we
discovered with svb UK many of these
many of the customers were businesses
they've got to provide payroll on a
Monday you've got you've got real issues
around their you know their continuity
of business that you know and it that
would be whether they were a tech firm
or whether a manufacturer you have to
you have to think yeah
I have a question I'm sure on the small
Banks regime but it's longer to pick up
the Edinburgh
unfortunate
going on to Andrea now
okay yeah great yeah all right love you
Andrew sorry not thank you thank you
very much we all worked through the
Fallout of the last financial crisis and
I think the thing that stays with me is
their heads I win tails you lose
approach of bankers and so on a yes or
no answer are each of you content that
it's reported that SBB and Credit Suisse
will continue to pay bonuses to their
staff
are you content
can I use that with more than one word
uh no I I'd like yes or no and then you
can have more than one word but I'd like
to know if you're content with that
I just can't answer the question it says
being one word because I need to talk
about which bit of the bank we're
talking about okay
UK is is the bit of directly within our
baby okay but let me ask it in another
way in what other sector in the UK if
your boss fails if your business fails
do you then get a bonus
well obviously that's not a normal
Arrangement
um what I would just say about svb UK is
that you know what happened here was an
issue with the parent
crystallized any other business well it
has a UK end of a international business
where else would you get paid a
significant bonus the point I'm getting
at isn't this creating moral hazard on a
grand scale which is that no matter
where I work if I'm in financial
services there is no downside for me
personally but that's why we have in
place a regime by which bonuses have to
be deferred and then they can be taken
back but will they be well that's that's
because we don't I don't think any of us
yet know the facts around that so we're
not going to comment on that but what we
do have in this country and it's
actually pretty unique to this country
actually it's a regime where bonuses are
deferred over a period of time a period
of years and have to be surrendered if
you know facts come to light either in
the performance of individual
performance The Firm subsequently which
means that that's the appropriate thing
to do we can't comment on credit Suites
because that's a Swiss issue okay but
the
Delight you know svb went bust Credit
Suisse went bust they've both been
bought rather than resolved they would
have had to have been resolved otherwise
and yet their subsidiaries in the UK
their branches in the UK will still get
their bonuses is that reasonable well
here's to say I'd make I would make a
distinction here between what happened
in the UK and by the UK bank of svb and
what happened at the group level so so
the UK entity was well capitalized it
was Liquid the issue that knocked it out
was that an issue crystallized a group
which immediately spread into the UK and
led to a run so I don't I don't think
that you know obviously that there have
been quite severe consequences for
anyone any executive that held any of
their wealth in stock in those Banks
um but I do think that you you need to
look to what happens in the U.S
um and yeah I'm quite sure there will be
some quite significant consequences
there the Swiss have made some state
Andrew said it's not yet quite clear
exactly how they're going to handle
um Credit Suisse but I would I would I
know it's not the most important thing
in the world to say but I would draw
that distinction between what happened
in the UK I think if any taxpayer funds
have been involved in the UK in either
these entities would be in a very very
different situation
I completely understand that but the
fact is that SBB did not have to go bust
it went bust because of the high risk
taking
um activities of Bankers in svb
um who in the UK who are Party to that
regardless of whether they're in a
usefully ring fence structure and as you
said yourself Sam and I think the
governor said it was previously a branch
it was only forced to become a UK ring
fence bank so suddenly by virtue of
action taken by you the UK bank is now
ring fenced and so you're able to say
well I would draw a distinction between
the UK bank and the U.S parent is that
fair is that fair okay on this occasion
not to the taxpayer but to those who are
in effect paying for the financial
system is it right that Bankers still
get bonuses even after what we saw
that's why I mean that's a good part why
we have this regime whereby those
bonuses then how to be deferred but
you've just said yourself Governor that
you don't know if what will be the
situation in svb or CSF well we haven't
had that discussion yet but you will
well I'm sure it will be part of the
supervision of the firm yeah
okay and in terms of the senior
certification senior managers and
certification regime do you think that
um there will be anyone who is held
personally liable for the risks that
have been taken either in svb or csfb
um look I don't want to get ahead of
where we are on either those cases
um
um Credit Suisse
has had you know a number of issues
through time which accumulated in this
event and there's obviously been
enforceable action taken against credits
recent in a number of ways in a
different jurisdictions
um I think Silicon Valley Bank UK say I
really want to comment on in detail but
I would come back to the observation I
made which is about the distinction as I
see it and you may or may not buy it but
between what happened in the UK and the
way the UK to his run and what happened
you know in terms of how that was sorted
out in the UK and and what happened in
the US I think there is a distinction
there you do seem to be saying well all
the way through this evidence session
Sam that um our regulation is better
than anyone else's and I'm not putting
words in your mouth that's how I'm
hearing it and you can you can disagree
but nevertheless is it not there for the
case that you as uh pra are going to
have to look very carefully at all of
the activities going on where
headquarters are somewhere else in order
to ensure that we don't just see this as
wholesale where we end up owning a
problem that perhaps we can deal with
Where It's a UK ring fenced entity but
where in the case of svb if it hadn't
been if it hadn't become UK ring fence
it would have been a massive problem for
us not of our doing through regulation
somewhere else that we disagree with
it had to become a subsettiary because
we have a policy that said you've hit a
trigger and you have to become a
subsidiary so there is a but if it was a
million pounds under that trigger it
wouldn't have hit that trigger so that
that is you know that is fate that is
just how it happened
to the bank the bank was gross
grew up and therefore it had to change
so were you saying then that had it been
slightly smaller and therefore it hadn't
hit that trigger that the issue for the
UK would have been easy I mean I think
it's the case that actually our
supervisors said to it back in 2020 you
are on a trajectory which means you will
have to subsidiarize and so they did so
if this had happened in 2019
it was a much smaller institution at
that point we still had to deal with it
but it was a much smaller so you're
saying that actually even in small Banks
the smaller end of small banks will
present fewer systemic fewer
regulatory issues okay refer back to
something Sam said early on in US
hearing this has been true for the pra
ever since we started it 10 years ago we
do not operate a no failure regime
because that would have all sorts of
consequences if we did that maybe I
could just add two brief comments well
one yeah I do not contend that our
regulation is better than everyone
else's I just think that would be a very
foolish thing to do and a particularly I
have great respect for the the US and
the way they run their system as it
happens in this case there are some
differences which is what I was alluding
to
um but on your your broader point there
is of course something in this so we are
a very large host of branches so on the
latest ones I have we've got 6.3
trillion pounds in branches in this
country it's more than 150 branches that
I think is a necessary condition if we
want to run a very large financial
center but we've made a judgment as
Andrew says around where to draw the
line in terms of what makes you have to
become a subsidiary and we've enforced
that there is I think a legitimate
question which may be what you're sort
of angling at
um which I think we do need to reflect
on is you know in light of you know how
the system is evolving is that threshold
in exactly in the right place might it
be in another place yeah I think that is
an open question but I but I I wouldn't
want to impress upon you that we make a
a risk Choice here that we host a lot of
branches and it's set out very clear in
Andrew's letter when you've got a branch
you are massively more dependent on the
home and there is of course some risk in
that Arrangement okay well thank you
very much I would certainly be
interested to see the outcome of um both
the senior managers and certification
regime in terms of Executives of svb and
Credit Suisse in the UK but also to see
whether in fact they do Implement their
um deferrals of bonuses and so on and
frankly why would bonuses be paid in any
case and I I still would assert that
actually it's uh their good fortune that
they were in a UK ring fence bank
because if they hadn't been they
presumably would not be getting bonuses
now
thank you thank you Andrea yeah
thank you Chad
one of the tools in the bank's toolbox
to deal with inflation is to increase
the interest rate but I think events
have made it very clear that it's never
quite that simple there are macro and
microeconomic events which mean that
there are other things that have to be
considered when you make those decisions
by the interest rates
in the market certainly among the fund
managers there is a a growing concern
that what we do at the moment and
increasing uh interest rate rise will
give rise to pressure
do you share that concern I've divided
into two parts so when we are setting
monitorship I'll take multi decisions
we always have to take into account
credit conditions uh in the UK and we
always do that and you know we did it
last week when we talked took the
decision last week and that's normal
now I would say in our agents our
regional agents have said this we see
some evidence of some tightening and
credit conditions but we do not see
a critical development development in
that respect moreover and in the context
of financial policy committee we think
that the banking system in this country
has uh you know ample capacity to lend
to support credits and what would you do
if that didn't happen yeah
I just wanted so two more points I'll
come to that point you just made as a
second I don't mind what I what I would
draw a distinction is that what because
and we said this in the letter to you
that we judge the UK banking system to
be stable safe and sound is that the MPC
which received that assessment by the
way that you have also received it from
the FBC was able to conclude last week
that it did not have to if you like aim
off monetary policy
uh because of the stability of the
financial system
that's important to be able to take that
decision without it and that's it the
point you rightly made what would we do
if we if we felt that capacity to be
able to support credits in the economy
was was compromised in any way all
threatened well the first thing we'd do
in the FPC is to lower the what we call
the ccyb the the counter cyclical
Capital buffer
um which we which we have we've set at
two percent for for the banks and we can
do that we didn't join the covert we did
it immediately when the covert period
started and we could do it again now our
current judgment is that in the last
round of the FPC the next one is coming
up next week
is that we did not think that the credit
conditions in this country required us
to to take an action to release that
buffer to support credit creation and
the economy we don't think the system is
under that stress but if it were that's
the action we would take
and just to correct the FPC is coming
out tomorrow I'm sorry
next day not last week I've been up too
many nights
um
Governor one of the things that has been
of concern I think uh which seems to
have driven much change uh very quickly
which has been difficult to deal with is
the speed with which you've raised
interest rates now we all appreciate
that events uh have put all the pressure
and that action has been necessary but
in hindsight do you think there were
a different strategy different different
if you like sensors that you could have
had which would have made you think
about increasing interest rates slowly
earlier which they wouldn't have had are
the consequences that we now see I have
to have said before and I'm afraid I'm
going to say it again that we don't have
the luxury of hindsight decision making
so I I really will say that I'm afraid
um what it will say is I think it comes
back to something Sam was saying earlier
is that and I you know I absolutely
agree with the point we don't have a
yeah we don't think our regulatory
system is perfect if you think that
you're heading for a fall straight away
so I don't want to go to get to that
point but what I would say is that
as some describe the way in which we
treat the so-called interest rate risk
in banks in the banking book as we call
it the fact that it has to go through to
the profit and loss accounts and
therefore hits hits capital and that we
require Capital amongst against those
risks that are not treated in that way
means that we are when we are in a I
think in a good position from the point
of view of assessing the impact of
raising interest rates on the position
of the banks themselves
yeah that that that's a that's a sense
of risk that we do not have to
in a sense factor in because it's taken
care of in the regulatory system in that
sense
you say you don't have uh if you like
2020 vision and that's the benefit of
hindsight but foresight clearly is
something which I imagine you're now
going to be looking at yes we do yeah
but much more seriously I think it was
yesterday you commented that you had a
concern about early retirees and the
impact that might have on inflation
how seriously do you take that risk and
what other things looking forwards now
that we know we need to be more Vigilant
what I said yesterday
um was in the context I was actually
really making a speech about the role of
the supply side of the economy
uh in in what we experience and saying
that during the last three years it's
actually had a bigger role than you
would might normally normally in normal
conditions think the point about Labor
Supply is that we have had over the last
three years an increase in so-called
inactivity that is people who are not
working and not seeking to work
now many countries had that in the early
stage of covid
um many many of those countries that has
now reversed itself but it hasn't really
reversed itself here and it is
concentrated in more in the 50 to 64
year old uh age group
now
there are two things going on here one
of which would have happened anyway
which of course the population is aging
and so that would of course have
happened covert or no covid but we've
also seen this additional uh effect
that's happened during the During the
period of covert and that has tightened
the labor markets uh relative to what we
would normally expect
the point I made last night was that
there was there was a point and we've
discussed this many times here if you
want to say I know where you know if you
go back to the summer and Early Autumn
or the Autumn of 2021 which is what was
going to happen when the furlough scheme
ended
now we thought and by the way we thought
rather less than most other forecasters
if you look back and forecasted it would
leave some increase in in unemployment
that there would be a sort of so-called
scarring in the economy that some firms
would not be able to
business and it would lead to
unemployment and some slack in the
economy but it didn't
uh it didn't and what it led to or what
happened was that there was an increase
in inactivity in the economy which means
that of course labor market isn't
smacking again so
and a supply side has played a role in
that now you know that was a judge
you're right about four sites we have to
use it all the time and that was a
judgment we had to make
um and things did turn out differently I
absolutely wanted that I I would say and
we publish in every martial policy
reports a um a box which got to what
other forecasters are thinking actually
my other Focus for unemployment will go
up more than we did but yeah that's
that's by the buy the point is yes that
was a that was a you know a judgment
that that was key at the time and it has
turned out to be different and if I
could just add two points to that one it
was actually at this committee last May
that we had a discussion around these
issues around labor participation that
our analysis has
um contributed to and and has brought
brought it up the agenda I think
um and you now see it very much as a
focus of government policy to to
increase uh participation engagement
with the labor market I mean the second
thing I'm just say and it sort of comes
back to where we started I mean we've
been we're very conscious on the
monetary policy committee that we are
putting up uh rates and having to put up
rates uh markedly because we're
concerned about the persistence in
inflation
in terms of all of us are on the
financial policy committee we've been
flagging concerns around you know what
what might be the implications of that
increase in interest rates for whether
it's for the you know we've been
particularly focused on non-bank uh what
we call market-based Finance we've had
you know following what we saw happening
with the ldi episode where because of
um fiscal events we saw a very sharp
increase in long-term rates
um what the impact of that was but you
know long-term rates have been going up
more progressively and that you know
Pension funds and the like have had to
adjust to that because the inflation
environment and the interest rate
environment has been changing and I
remember you know discussing this you
know we were asked well where could the
next risk crystallize and you know we're
we're super alive too you know whether
those risks can crystallize in the
banking sector we've got the regulation
to deal with that but also you know we
have to be very Vigilant to those risks
from higher interest rates playing out
in other parts of the economy and and
that plays into the the volatile and
challenging environment we're in
we're up against the Bell so I just want
to reiterate my thanks uh Governor
um Sam today
um to you for coming in at short notice
to give us this update also to all of
your teams for all of the hard work they
did uh through the night
um going through this live stress test
of the regime that has been put in place
and the test of your toolbox and I know
that you'll keep us posted as to how you
look forward to adjusting your stress
test for the lessons that have been
learned as a result of this live one
um I think that as Anne-Marie was just
flagging the question as to what impact
this will have on the real economy and
the tightness of the financial markets
in the UK is still an open question so I
know that we will have more questions
for you on that flag up of course to the
watching public that we are doing an
inquiry on quantitative tightening and
the uh fact that not many people really
know what the impact of that might be
and we will be coming in and doing some
evidence sessions at the bank itself and
just to reiterate the need for vigilance
thank you for your Vigilant gentlemen
and order order I declare this session
closed